oh hello before we talk to RFK Jr
letting you know that I am going to be
in Eerie Pennsylvania at the Warner
Theater June 28th 20124 assuming I don't
die in childbirth then I will be in Las
Vegas Nevada July 6th 2024 performing at
the Mirage it will be all new material
about how a vampire tore through my body
we'll see not sure I'm taking some time
off to write some brand new material for
y'all and then after that I'm going to
meet Edmonton Alberta Canada July 17th
2024 the Great Outdoors Comedy Festival
Bert ker will also be there I also have
a new special out it's on
of.tv Whitney don't overthink it o f
period
TV Whitney you're going to see my brand
new standup special uncensored
free please
enjoy oh Shalom here we go B B B it's a
big day presidential hopeful Robert
Kennedy Jr's on the podcast look I was
going to do an open where I was like
defensive like I know you guys may have
read that he did this
and and I was like you know what I'm not
GNA do that I'm not gonna do a big
defensive open because that would imply
that we don't have dope listeners of
this podcast okay you guys get it you
want to hear anti-establishment
anti-corruption smart people talk I
don't think any of you believe in
silencing presidential candidates right
you're not a bunch of snitchy dorks so
I'm not going to do that but if you are
listening and you're like RFK has spread
some vacine Miss
for
okay even if that's true let's say it's
true how do you
know how do you know how do you but you
this drives me not someone will be like
he said the vaccines caused
the and you're like what did you have to
step away from your mic scope to make
this point like how how do you know Dale
who works in marketing ad dicts Sporting
Goods how would you know Amber who's
never read a book in her life really
you're G to you're going to shut down
this
conversation at a party Taylor who fell
off a bird scooter last week high on
Edibles so you're the authority on
vaccines like when I ask
people like about this and they'll be
like no no no no no I went on the New
York times the New York Times told man
the New York the gay
blog I mean it's just you trust the news
site who want his Twitter feed will post
the death toll of children in Gaza then
two tweets later will post about a new
Twist on Avocado toast like I don't I'm
not trying to come for the New York
Times but they did just hire a
journalist who praised Hitler I'm just I
I don't know okay you're right I'm not
trying to come for the New York Times
times all right it's just that all of
these news organizations are funded by
the very corporations he
criticizes so it's all a little fishy if
you ask me it's like airport Sushi level
fishy so I just I feel like who cares
what you like be honest just let's be
honest with oursel no one knows anything
okay you you know this is my forever
take on everything and if you just
listen to like sound bites you would
think that RFK like this vaccines no he
totally dimensionalized his argument he
did say that in 1989 vaccine schedule
increased but he also said there was a
ton of other variables cell phone
started Roundup chemicals were
introduced GMOs he says that it could be
a bunch of variables in terms of the
autism thing okay 1989 was a year where
a bunch of new stuff came into the mix
could have caused an increase could have
been anything maybe Bill Cosby's ruies
got into the water supply it could have
been anything he's not saying it's that
it's just I know it's hard to listen to
Long conversations it's hard to listen
to anything they can't fit into a Tik
Tok in a minute I get it but there's too
many variables to know and don't be
don't blame me I don't know what to tell
you okay blame your
simulator who has been called to dinner
by his mom and who dropped the remote
from the years 2021 to 2023 hopefully he
comes back to the couch soon and doesn't
get distracted by the popup ad on the
screen for a flashlight we might lose
another couple years and I'm just saying
if you agree disagree with RFK you have
to admit that it is cool that he's been
going after corporations for like 40
years or something uh he's the only
person with the audacity to say that big
Pharma should not advertise on
television which I agree it is a wild
conflict of interest but more
importantly their commercials suck they
make shitty commercials big Pharma
commercials first of all they're like 3
minutes long and why am I watching a
white woman in a vest in a canoe like if
your medication is going to make me want
to be a canoe person that is the number
one problematic side effect of this pill
like hair loss LOL laido I can handle
that but if this medication makes me
want to get into a
canoe I mean every one of these
commercials are insane like according to
Big Pharma everyone who takes Val tracks
ends up hysterically laughing on a hike
like why is everyone in every Pharma ad
just outside maniacally laughing like
get inside like I just cured my rosacea
now I got all this free time to go out
and get Lyme disease and push my wife
off a cliff just stay inside everyone go
back to studying the vaccine since
everyone's a scientist now go back to
your vaccine research because Twitter
needs
you anyway I don't I don't normally
weigh in on politics and don't panic I'm
not going to weigh in on Politics on the
podcast with RFK Ji we kind of talk
about you know it doesn't get too into
the weeds but I do think it is safe to
say that the two-party system is broken
like I mean a qualm that people have
with him right now is they'll be like
he's going to take votes from Democrats
and Republicans is that bad maybe they
need some competition maybe they
need to step up maybe a third party
person will make them have to actually
run candidates who aren't 200 years old
RFK is going to steal votes okay hey
like you mean some voters aren't going
to have to choose the least worst also
why do they why do they even call a
Republican party or Democratic party
there's not a lot to celebrate right now
they just call like the Democratic cult
and the
Republican ho down debutant I don't know
I just I don't understand why our only
options for presidents are either the
tannest people on Earth or the palest
people on Earth all the Republican
candidates they look like shiny hanb
elector and the Democrats all look like
vegan an who have scurvy is can anyone
just be in the middle I'm I guess I'm a
middle person now I'm in the middle and
that's not a copout it's not fun to be
in the middle okay it's like being the
middle person and a human centipede
either way it sucks also when it
comes to like the left and the right
like you know all of the right-wing
politicians and left-wing politicians
are friends right like that's the thing
no one talks about is that the
politicians on both sides they live in
the same places they have vacation homes
in the same places they're all in The
Hamptons or in Connecticut like a huge
Democratic politician lives right next
door to a huge Republican they share a
gardener that they both pay $3 an hour
they get each other's Amazon packages
like Nancy Pelosi's like hey Donald I
got your Sally Hanson self tanner again
do you want me to just throw it over you
know what let me text Bezos right now to
tell us to stop mixing up our packages
that's silly goose and if you have the
falder hiide I ordered can you let me
know cuz cuz I need to reapply it soon
don't want to start disintegrating
before this hot stock tip comes in PS
hey make sure to invest in hulet Packard
trust me they just made a 3D printer
that prints
babies they loan each other boats when
they need to kill the spouse they share
a
skippy for their boats they'll be like
are you using our Skippy this weekend or
can I get the Skippy I'm just saying
they're all friends okay but they all
right and left seem to be mad at Robert
Kennedy Jr which makes me think he's
doing something right is that a psycho
thing to think I just I just feel like
most Americans have to choose the least
worst candidate now and also politics is
like it's just become Sports it's like
sports for dorks at this point it's like
us versus them like it's like if you're
a Jets fan and you meet a Patriots fan
automatically you're mad at them it's
like with the left and the right it's
like he's a republican is that really
how you define a person by their
political party I don't do I don't I
Define people in a way that actually
dimensionalize them not based on whether
they're a Republican or a Democrat based
on whether they have a Samsung or an
iPhone I don't really care how you vote
as long as we have the same color bubble
we're cool so just for context he did
come into my house and he actually said
something that no one's ever said to me
that's come to my house he was like how
come you don't have any family photos
anywhere
he's like you don't live here do you why
he was like is this he was like is this
like a stage house like no this is my
house he's like there's no family photos
is that not the saddest thing you've
ever heard in your
life I mean I didn't know what to say I
like was speechless I was like no but we
have I have like pots on shelves like
what goes do family photos like what is
love like what is a family like I I was
at a loss like where do family photos go
I feel like they go to piano I don't
have a piano like should I have photos
of I mean everyone's either dead or
suing me you know what I mean should I
frame lawsuit letter should
I I guess I could have my mom's earn out
it would match all the other pots he
seemed really
bmed it seemed he seemed kind of like
like he's like are you okay
like he's like this is the lonliest
house I've ever seen is basically what
he's I would imagine any anyone who grew
up a Kennedy is just overwhelmed with
family photos on the wall I bet I bet
yeah we we don't do a lot of photo
evidence in our family we don't we don't
want anyone to know that we cross paths
we don't want any proof this is all like
like evidence in future lawsuits we
don't do a lot of
pictures but yeah I mean I guess I never
thought about that until until now it
was the first thing he
noticed well the first thing he wanted
to talk to you about I know he's like
why don't you have any family photos I
was like because I what then it's going
to take up all the space and I can't
have the dog figurines and the David
Bowie figurine and where are the horse
statue is going to go but this is
cluttered up with a bunch of people that
love me you're like what 13-year-old
girl do you know that has family photos
all over their room it was kind of
heartbreaking um yeah I guess he also
has like a hundred
cousins yeah you know yeah their family
and their family history is yeah every
that's their whole thing is the photos
that reinforce the dynasty my family's
not big on admitting we know each other
or Cort in any
capacity we don't we don't frame photos
we frame each
other oh gosh I just I felt so bad for
him like that he had to pointed like he
was just like should I tell her he was
he was totally just like flabbergast
I've never I've never seen someone have
that kind of reaction to my house before
he was like trying to say like are you
okay but he was just like where are the
family
photos all right well all right does
anyone want to send me some photo you
know I could just buy frames and just
leave you know it always comes with a
photo of someone they seem like nice
people yeah like it's like a black and
white photo I'll just like get some
photos from like the Hallmark store or
what's it called
the
moments Precious Moments tender moments
I don't even know where to buy Aaron
Brothers Aaron Brothers I don't even
know where to buy photo frames to put
photos in but so um if you would like to
DM me some photos of your family and
Photoshop me in I'd really appreciate it
so we don't have to weird anyone else
out cuz I I am in the market for a
family um so that I can put photos
around my house so I don't have to see
the sadness on someone I mean it did bum
him
out I can't stop thinking about it okay
here he is
RFK this show is brought to you by
better help why because well I host
it I can't say enough good things about
what therapy has done for me in my life
I literally wrote a book about it okay I
had a condition called codependence
where I used to waste a lot of my time
doing things out of obligation I felt
guilty saying no to people I confuse
love and pity I felt guilt when I stood
up for myself I was scared of authority
figures I tried to make other people you
know like me instead of just focusing on
liking myself in short I was a wreck
folks I also put other people's needs
before my own how do you think I got
pregnant time skin I was always taking
care of everybody else but not taking
care of myself I wasn't eating well I
was texting and driving because I just
had to text back that friend who was
breaking up with her married boyfriend
for the fourth time it was all just
nonsense I tell you therapy helped me
realize that I got these behaviors
honestly therapy helped me rewire my
brain helped me make better decisions
and now I have six comedy specials and a
kid on the way you too can have it all
folks holidays are coming up and that's
that is really when things get a little
bit wobbly even if you have done a lot
of therapy you know grief comes up
pressure to socialize give gifts to
people that I don't even like
perfectionism around the
tree but look I I am still at the point
where I let people come over to help
decorate the tree and as soon as they
leave I redo the whole thing that will
never change that is just who I am no
amount of therapy is going to make me
let people do a sloppy ass tree but I am
going to double down on therapy this
holiday season as a gift to the people I
love so if you're thinking of starting
therapy give better help a try it's
entirely online designed to be
convenient flexible and suited to your
schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapist
at any time for no additional charge
find your bright spot this season with
betterhelp visit betterhelp.com Whitney
toay and get 10% off your first month
that's betterhelp
hp.com
Whitney I do think this house is unusual
because you don't live here right I live
here oh you do yes sir there's no like
personal pictures or photos or of the
house you mean oh in the house yeah
you're do you have a family
or I actually didn't even put that
together you know that is really sad it
seems like a show House it does seem
stage doesn't it yeah like a stage that
yeah it's so I mean we're but we're on
opposite you want me to come and help
you you have a thousand photos I bet on
every piano in your well I I have a
story because Cheryl doesn't like
clutter and we don't we although we have
some big walls in our house we don't
have like I
had
um I have Fram signatures from all the
presidents in different
frames and you know stuff like that my
family have hundreds and hundreds of
photos but almost none of it is up at my
house because uh Cheryl does not like
clutter it's I do have a a complicated
relation with my family lost both
parents uh
relatively recently but yeah I think I
tried to do Sanctuary vibe in there and
then this is my peewee's fun house this
room looks it's it's always good to have
like I feel like one room just put all
your clutter in it's just the Clutter
room and but yeah no you really did just
make me take a good hard look at myself
on that we because I know you have a
heart out and I um do not want to waste
your time but just want to start with
saying you know you've been doing a lot
of podcasts I'm sorry about these
comedians iar I
apologize I had a great I mean Tim Dylan
and uh Theo I know your buddies with him
good buddies yeah and uh uh and Bobby
Lee Bobby Lee which by the way I
listened to it last night just to be
like let me make sure I'm not asking any
of the same questions yeah and that's
not a good thing to listen to and then I
come up at the end he's like yeah I'm
friends with Whitney Cummings we show
each other our genital I was like wait
hold on that has never happened first of
all can I hire you to sue him for me
that is blasphemy and I will not
participate oh I can't believe we went
to the same elementary school so weird
of course decades aart in Georgetown I
went to Holy Trinity uh Our Lady of
Victory and then graduated from St and I
went to our lady Victory wouldn't it be
weird if some of the teachers that I had
miss school again was she still there oh
I don't think I don't think so but that
would be such a trip yeah um yeah I use
I was
at that point in my life I was really I
would say non-c compus menst I I think I
was so ADHD that I could not even
understand what you know uh it just
sounded like audible chaos coming out of
the teachers mouths and I would sit
there and you could look at the
MacArthur Reservoir and there were black
vultures and turkey vultures and Herring
gulls and all of these animals that I
was interested in and I would just sit
there all day and watch those birds and
uh and I was I think I was the lowest
person in my
class until I started taking drugs and I
you know I think I was self-medicating
and then I went to the top of my class
in ninth grade I
started uh you know self-medicating and
I went and suddenly I could fine I could
sit still and I could concentrate with
Heroin okay nice nice right yeah I mean
no I mean I was just I'm listening to
there's a Harvard scientist who talks
about micro doing heroin and it really
helps with his
Focus that's not a good idea no for sure
not also doesn't last the micro do part
it made me allowed me to focus it
allowed me it calmed down my mind and I
could read for the first time and then I
just became a you know voracious
reader um but uh before that I had like
a squirrels you know in my head and it's
fascinating cuz I you know I'm almost
eight months pregnant now and uh sorry
was moving a little slow this morning
trying to get you in well you
look felt and so I don't want to ask you
any questions that you've been asked a
million times um can I start on a little
bit of positive note like can I just say
what is America doing well right
now long beat well I I would I mean
there are certain areas that I think we
still are kind of world leader on um I
we probably build the best aircraft in
the world um we uh we I think we still
do Innovation better than anybody else
you know Silicon Valley and Boston and
these Innovation
centers where you have this
extraordinary very very Americanized
entrepreneurial
firment um so we're on The Cutting Edge
we don't build the the microchips but we
design them and we do all of that kind
of you know Innovation is done in
America
um and then you know there's a lot of
really interesting things with happening
kind of on the
margins that are directly related to our
to the freedom of this country you know
one of those is integrative medicine and
functional medicine there's just this
this
explosion of innovation and knowledge
and again it's not coming from the
established institutions it's coming
from you know people very smart people
who are now who have chosen to have been
relegated to the
margins and are figuring out ways to
heal disease and to avoid disease and to
build your immune system and you know to
restore Health the same thing is
happening in regenerative agriculture
and um you know you're seeing these
again it's not coming from the
centralized institutions which are all
broken it's coming from individuals
operating outside of the system and this
is something you won't see in China
um because of the way that you know they
don't have that kind of Freedom so
people don't feel like they have
permission to think for themselves and
to do something unusual and to break
down barriers and I think we still have
that in this country and I think it's
all ultimately that's going to be the
key to our recovery as a nation and as a
moral Center in the world I've seen
Shark Tank I know all about this exactly
our Cuban you know I see a lot of people
sort of online and memes talking about
sort of the Constitution and you know
was written at a time where things were
different and da da da if you could
magically just wave a wand and add or
amend an amendment or change the
Constitution what would you do I I guess
I'd put a little addendum on every
Amendment saying uh there's no pandemic
exception there's no
exceptions you know I I think we saw
that I mean ultimately the Constitution
only works if people believe in it and
in the uh and see it as a you know as a
moral Milestone a moral
document and uh you know I think the
shocking thing in the during the
pandemic was how people were willing to
just um you know all of the all of the
the uh amendments basically came under
attack the First Amendment you know we
saw the censorship for the first time
government Opera you know ordained
censorship we then saw free freedom of
worship you we saw every Church in the
country closed for a year and also
something that I just must say
self-censorship I think also counts just
this this fear of if I say something oh
yeah well that happened too that's not
actionable yes it's actionable when the
government when the White House is
telling the you know Twitter you censor
Robert Kennedy or you censor Dr
mccullock or you censor Dr Corey or
we're going to pull your section 230
immunity and destroy your company which
is exactly what happened you know
anybody who doubts that description
should go look at judge out's decision
155 page decision of you know my case is
now the front of the US Supreme
Court um it's called Missouri ver versus
Biden and Kennedy versus Biden they're
Consolidated oh that's never happened
before and then they went after freedom
of religion they closed all the churches
no scientific citation no public
hearings no environmental impacts I mean
all of the kind of the IND dis of
democracy were simply
abandoned and then they went after the
third part of the soci the First
Amendment which is so um which is
freedom of
assembly they you know they mandated
social distancing and they they um they
began punishing people who were
demonstrating Etc and they went after uh
uh Fifth Amendment property rights they
shut down every business in our country
3.3 million businesses with no process
no just
compensation they went after jury trials
seventh amendment guarantees jury
trial in any matter to any citizen in
the United States cannot be denied the
right of a jury of a trial before the
jury of his
peers in case their controversies
exceeding $25 that's what the amendment
says that's it there's no pandemic
exception and yet you know anybody who
is involved in a
countermeasure they got rid of jury
trials if they no matter how negligent
they are no matter how badly injured you
are no matter how Reckless their
behavior no matter how toxic the
ingredients or shy they're testing you
can't sue
them and um so and then they got rid of
the Fourth Amendment prohibitions
against warrantless searches and
seizures um you have to give your
medical information before you go into a
building public building or whatever
that's never happened before so all the
and by the way the framers the con
stitution knew all about
epidemics there were two epidemics
during the American uh Revolution one of
them a malaria epidemic that decimated
the armies of
Virginia and there was a smallo epidemic
that that absolutely
froze the army of New England at a very
critical time in fact at that time
Benedict Arnold conquered Montreal oh he
made it into the inner city he took the
city we own it for a day but he couldn't
hold it because his troop strength was
so depleted by small box he had to
retreat out of the city wow and
otherwise Canada today would be part of
the United
States and all the framers knew that wow
so and they and and between the end of
the Revolution and the ratification of
the Bill of Rights there were epidemics
in every city there were small poox
Cera malaria epidemics uh yellow fever
that killed tens of thousands of people
almost everybody who saw who was part of
the Constitutional Convention their
lives and their families were were
touched by those epidemics and didn't
put it in right yet they didn't say well
they didn't say they didn't put an
epidemic exception next you know on
anything they didn't say these these
amendments only are are
good unless um unless there's an
epidemic unless Bill Gates predicted an
epidemic exactly this makes me so angry
when I hear about this and I go okay I'm
just I got to vote I got to vote I just
got to inform myself something I really
bump on is the fact that our um election
day is not a holiday um is that
something that you think who does it
serve Why does it serve my sorry to be
tin full hack guy I just go oh great
poor people can't vote people that don't
have cars can't vote people that have
jobs and can't afford babysitters can't
vote um should voting be a national
holiday I would say that I haven't
thought about it but I would say that's
a good idea of course it's wild to me
that it's not and it seems like it
serves people who uh can afford to take
the day off or people that you know yeah
have no that's a good point basically
more resources and what about um age
limits on the Supreme Court is that am I
agest I I'm not for age limits I think
you know you might have competency tests
or something like that but um you know
age limits because I know people who are
90 years old and who have cognitive
capacity and the fluidity and
lucidity of people who are in their 50s
oh it's
really you know to me it's more that's a
really
individualized you can't just say I mean
and you know people who try
to impose age limits there's a lot of
seniors in this country who vote and
they're and and they're offended by it
because a lot of them are like I'm
completely okay why are you going to
make a law against me totally totally
it's like your driver's license when you
get to an age you have to start getting
tested yeah it's more like the the yeah
it's it it's more um you know I work in
um the you know rescuing exotic animal
trafficking stuff and there's something
um called founder syndrome this God comp
yeah I know what that
is where the longer you've been in power
sort of the power corrupts your brain
over long periods of time it's not the
age itself it's kind of more sort of the
power at the end of the day there was a
great article in the Atlantic about what
power does to the brain um can I can I
ask you real quick just in terms of um
you've been so open by your sobriety and
so many people are so grateful uh for
that um as I said I'm in a 12-step
program and um in our 12-step programs
we do something called a 10 step every
night where we go do our inventory of
what we're resentful for maybe where we
owe an apology if it's do um uh where we
need to forgive somebody what's coming
up in your 10 step these days in terms
of resentments that you might need to
turn over I'm pretty good about not
hanging on to resent you'd have to be
then yeah I mean I learned that really
on it you know there's there's two ways
that most people process uh conflict and
anger and one of those ways is to
internalize it and to turn it into a
resentment and and that is like
swallowing poison and hoping someone
else will die it's corrosive and the
other way is to externalize it turn it
into anger or
rage which then spreads it like a you
know like a ripples all across the globe
you get angry you kick the dog the dog
bites somebody else you get them angry
at your wife she you know she at
somebody at
work and it it it ripples across the
glob so neither of those is a good way
to do it and I I think the technique for
handling anger has to be learned by most
people that it doesn't come across it's
counterintuitive which is that you go to
the source of your anger and then you
explain how you feel about it you know
without pointing the finger without
using the word I tell people don't use
the word you don't say you did this to
me to say that encounter we had um
here's how I processed it you know my
feelings were hurt from it or or
something but without telling that
person you did this to me yep so you say
what you mean without saying it
mean and uh uh you know and it's all
technique and it's something that you
have to learn but I have learned that
over you know 40 years and of you know
practicing those so I clear
up my I clear up my
um you know my
anger any instance that very very
quickly and I won't go to sleep at night
holding resentment against somebody or
or
when I sometimes in the middle of the
night I'll I'll I'll I'll have like
almost like a dream
state or I wake up in the middle of
night and I go into this kind of
contemplative Twilight Zone you know
when you're way trying to get back to
sleep and I feel like God talks to me in
those moments and that during those
moments I'll think of something oh you
said this to this guy today and you were
joking but he probably took it you know
probably heard it
as soon as I figure that out I make a
call and I get rid of it I neutralize
because I don't want to walk around with
any of that stuff could have handled
that better hope that didn't yeah I mean
it is such a miracle um it's a miracle
too because you know another technique
is to pray for somebody that
you um that injures you and I learned
this really on in um in you know in
dealing with road rage
oh that if somebody gives you a finger
on the road I mean I remember a time
when I turned my car around and chase a
guy or 12 miles from White PLS to to
sum exit on with no plan no real plan no
but then I got into physical conflict
with him on the top of the exit ramp
when he got off then I go home and I'm
saying I'm I'm driving home and I'm late
for the appointments that I was supposed
to do that day and I have this rage in
my head and the guy is living in my head
rentree MH and that
stranger Now controls the rest of my day
and you know controls my happiness and
my you know capacity to to maximize
my impact on the world and and my my
feeling of of well-being and all that
and so I somebody told me when somebody
does that to you on the highway or they
cut you off or they do something to
immediately just say prayer for
them and it was like a miracle cuz it
just went away and I I'm sitting there
saying that's like a drug you just do it
and it goes away and now you don't have
to do anything now you know I'm in
control of my own life I don't I'm not
handing control over to a total stranger
so that really helped me and then in
larger things um I had
somebody who was a close friend of mine
a couple years ago who did who I helped
this person in ways that were you know I
I literally spent a year of my life um
doing something for this person that got
him out of
prison and uh and that person did
something to me that was you know that
was not
good and I have not spent one minute
feeling resentful or anger against my I
should I have a right
to I haven't because I've been able to
manage my you know I manage my anger in
that way and I'm not you know I I feel
very loving towards them and very
forgiving
and um and very and I every day I spent
a little time praying that good things
happen to him and what that does for me
is it makes it that I never walk around
with that bitterness inside of me
because whatever he did was ultimately
self harm because he lost you whatever
it was I the only way can really hurtt
me is if I allow it to and if I just
send good energy toward
him um then I you know it's uh uh you
know then it it has no impact on me and
it's it's really been to me it's an it's
kind of like a hidden accomplishment for
me because I was able to process this
whole event without ever experiencing
resentment or anger something that um
you know sounds like a platitude but
they really helped me in program to
simplify the complicated brain of we
forgive others not because they deserve
forgiveness but because we deserve peace
yeah so well that's a really good way
you just said what I said in 10
minutes I should have just said that can
I write that down now I I don't know if
you guys noticed this or not but I have
recently become a fashion icon I don't
know I I've decided to become the Jackie
O of comedy and pair my vintage gas
station horse shirts with some very chic
Basics I feel like a lot of Brands I
used to like for simple Basics went
insane and started bedazzling everything
and losing their mind so now I really
only shop at flea markets or Quint
because Quint has these I I can't even
tell you these like amazingly classic
styles that make you seem like you have
way more class than you actually do and
suddenly I feel like I'm shiv from
succession I'm in a creamy taupe these
days I'm I'm dabbling with a rustic
Brown a steal your man heather gray try
and stop me you can't Quin offers a
range of high quality items with prices
Within Reach like 100% Mongolian catmere
sweaters from $50 washable silk tops
washable silk you heard that not high
maintenance you got to take it to the
lady to wash for you silk tops washable
silk tops dresses cotton sweaters and
cozy pants you know me I also love gift
giving it's actually like a mental
problem but it can really add up that's
why this holiday season I'm shopping at
Quin Quint is my go-to place for luxury
Essentials and affordable prices for
everyone on my list me particularly I'm
getting everybody luggage travel stuff
they have the cutest like fanny packs
and like roller bags best part all Quint
items are priced 50 to 80% less than
similar Brands so you're not getting
conned or scammed by partnering directly
with top factories Quin cuts out the
cost of the middleman and passes on the
savings to us and Quint only works with
factories that use safe ethical respons
manufacturing practices and premium
fabrics and finishes you're not going to
get your item and then have a bunch of
children's sweat and blood on it I love
this about Quint I got this it's so cute
it's an eggshell white cashmere
button-down sweater I've been pairing
with this sundress that I had to just
pull out of the washing thing because
I've been wearing it forever look at how
cute this brown is this sundress okay
I'm a total '90s dream girl all of a
sudden look at this I'm Rona Rider in
Reality Bites meets live Tyler and
Empire Records H in my vanilla milkshake
colored sweater that is bringing all the
boys to the yard and by yard I mean
YouTube comment section being like wait
is Whitney my dream girl and the answer
is yes I actually am I'm classy yet not
intimidating I'm fashionable yet not
desperate because I was smart enough to
shop at Quint get affordable luxury for
everyone on your list with Quint go to
quinn.com Whitney for free shipping on
your order and 365 day returns that's
Quin u i n c e here's the label look how
cute on my Quin dress Quin look how
adorable quinn.com Whitney to get free
shipping and 365 day return sorry about
the burping but I'm classy remember
because I wear beautiful brown tones
quince.
Whitney selling a little or selling a
lot Shopify helps you do your thing
however you
ching Shopify is the global Commerce
platform that helps you sell at every
stage of your business from the launch
your online shop stage to the first real
life store stage all the way to the did
we just hit a million orders stage
Shopify is where you are going to go
grow Shopify is where to help you grow
whether you're selling scented soap or
offering outdoor outfits Shopify helps
you sell everywhere from their
all-in-one e-commerce platform to their
in-person POS system wherever and
whatever you're selling shopify's got
you covered Shopify helps you turn
browsers into buyers with the internet's
best converting checkout 36% better on
average compared to other leading
Commerce platforms and sell more with
less effort thanks to Shopify magic your
AI powered Allstar so what I love about
Shopify is how no matter how big you
grow Shopify gives you everything you
need to take control and take your
business to the next level Shopify is a
total Game Changer because the interface
is so easy even an idiot like me could
figure it out you all know that I have a
book that I wrote It's Easy not only to
sell the book but also to update buyers
with information about the book being
late because I don't know some nightmare
happens and then I can send a message
thanking them it also tells me who
bought the book and where so I can start
seeing patterns and change the way that
I market so it's like if a bunch of
people are buying in Toledo this book I
go like I should maybe go on tour in
Toledo because all these people bought
my book there's so much feedback there's
such a way to take your business to the
next level it's genius I love it I don't
know why you'd ever use anything else
for something as important as your bid
Shopify poers 10% of all e-commerce in
the United States and Shopify the global
force behind Al Birds rothy and Brooklyn
and three of my favorite Brands and
millions of other entrepreneurs of every
size across 175 countries plus shopify's
award-winning help is there to support
your success every step of the way
because businesses that grow grow with
Shopify sign up for a $1 permon trial
period at shopify.com Whitney all
lowercase go to shopify.com Whitney now
to grow your business no matter what
stage you're in shopify.com
Whitney love
you when I first started going into the
rooms I was like oh God I don't need
this these people are depressed I'm too
busy for that you know whatever my ego
really trying to find ways that I didn't
need to be there oh I already get that
but then I heard um one thing um said by
um a brilliant guy still in my life he
got up and he said I have good news and
bad news the good news is the war is
over the bad news is you lost and it
just it's exactly what I needed to hear
exactly the way I needed to hear it
perfectly succinct and it just made me
surrender you know I was fighting the
god stuff I was fighting the steps I'm
too busy for this was there anything
that just was perfectly said that made
things click for
you I mean I said this the other day in
an interview that one of the things that
um that
uh really helped me was uh was a line
from Isaiah that said be still and know
that I am
God which um because my life was all
activity and no progress I was you know
I was always I was ambitious and I was
energetic and I put you know huge energy
into my life and you know I described
myself as being a giant truck stuck in a
ditch with the wheels spinning and the
you know headers smoking and the pipes
Flames coming to that pipe and roaring
noise and going nowhere you know and
then um I you know I I learn to be still
that I don't have to fix everything that
if if I don't if I I don't I you know I
I don't have to reach outside of myself
to fix things that are you know going
wrong inside of
me you know the parts of me that are you
know not feeling good good right now I
don't have to go out and fix that I can
just be still and that it will pass like
a storm cloud like lying on a hill and
watching Dark Cloud come and a white
cloud or
whatever and that if I can sit still
with that stuff that God does the hard
work and be peaceful be filled with
um with uh uh just with with peace and
that it's going to be handled it's not
my job it's it's people struggle with
the God thing and it makes me a lot more
efficient and effective as a human being
being able to be
still um and you know there's a story
about Abraham Lincoln who was asked
about how he would cut down he was the
rail splitter so he was you know handy
with an axe and he was asked about what
he would do if he had five hours to cut
down a an oak a giant oak tree and he
said he'd spend four hours sharpening
the
axe and to me that's a metaphor for you
know being in a good spiritual condition
if I'm in a good spiritual State I am
much more effective as a human being it
it not only takes that knot out of my
stomach of anxiety that I was born with
and that empty hole inside of myself
that I was trying to fill with drugs and
sex and risky extreme behavior and all
that it makes me peaceful inside but
also it somehow Alters the universe so
that my luck changes the lights turn
green the parking places and and that
you know uh people call when they're
supposed to there's a syn I see all
these little
synchronicities happening around me
these little coincidences and weird
Little Miracles that make me that feel
like God reaching in and touching me and
saying you know I got you so it just it
makes me such a magic trick it's such a
magic trick it's like you know when I'm
working with people that are sponses
that the god saying I don't believe in
God it's like okay you don't have to
believe in God yet just believing in God
let's just start with the fact it just
means you're not god let's just start
that you're not and you just see them go
oh thank God you know like I don't have
to be in control of everything I can
just be in the passenger seat and like
let the good things come and that don't
come aren't for you it's like the
rejections God's protection and when you
start seeing that and looking at it that
way you can't there's nothing bad can
ever happen to you because you can just
sublimate it into something positive or
and that's that's the trick is
that you know the trick that God has is
taking
chaos and uh you know and bringing order
out of it and each one of us is little
you know our sort of each our magical
ability is to do that in life to try to
whatever we encounter whatever bad thing
we encounter to try to make something
good out of it to process in the way
that you know you can be of use to other
people that you can you know how to
console people that you know what to say
that you can have that you gain wisdom
from it the word wisdom means a
knowledge of God's
Will and it means that you have an
instinctive knowledge about what is
right what's what's wrong and how to
turn you know bad things into something
good for somebody else and looking at it
as practice so if you didn't get what
you wanted practicing patience you
didn't get you know this is
uncomfortable today's my opportunity to
practice tolerating discomfort like you
can sort of step three you spin
everything into something that benefits
you yeah like the ultimate magic trick
um you mentioned um you know the concept
of getting internal needs met with
external things I feel like as you know
someone that is you know has so much
alcoholism and addiction in my family
and I look ahead and I look at all these
new addictions popping up which is just
the whack-a-mole you know um with social
media with self-righteous indignation on
Twitter you know when people go on
Twitter and they're like everyone's so
divided it's like yeah I mean you know
there was a Civil War at one point in
this we've been divided before you know
um maybe we just just see it more than
ever who knows but when I see negativity
online I just see people that are
addicted to self-righteous ignation
addicted to social media you know um
what is if any the government's role in
addiction recovery you've talked about
it a little bit but it's something that
you know I worry big farm is just going
to come in and be like we have the
addiction pill we've got the you know
they're already kind of doing it but is
it yeah that's what they're already
doing I mean they've
turned a lot of the rehab industry you
know that has has become predatory
because of that because it's been
captured by Pharma and they you go in to
try to get sober and they put you on you
know proac or ssris or benzos and um and
it just becomes part of the you know the
the um aprit center for the there an
alcohol pill that's coming out soon that
makes you puke if you drink it's called
joerger tequila yeah just eat the worm
I'm just always so curious because it
seems like something that you know
addicts to me are always the most
effective people on the planet the
smartest most big-hearted people on the
planet when they're sober but I just see
more and more um addictive substances
you know and behaviors yeah I mean my
and I get it is my my brain is like a
formulation Pharmacy I can turn anything
into a into a
drug um you know and all the things you
say you know substances or you know
coffee or Red Bull or uh you know or you
know emotional stuff like you know Pride
anger you know
Lusty average adrenaline adrenal
gambling I mean because gambling I mean
I look at you know Instagram and I go
these are just slot this is a slot
machine it's the same thing but I I also
think that like you know there's such a
thing as positive addictions you know
work and you know that kind of thing you
know so it's but you know the government
getting involved is that overstepping or
am
I no I mean you know what my kind of I
guess you'd call it a moonshot program
or um you know the pecore program you
know I'm going to start these Healing
Centers all across the country in rural
areas amazing right now the the um you
know the Big Industry in rural areas in
this country the only industry in a lot
of the rural areas is
prisons and we we had 106,000 people
dive overd doses main mainly fental last
year that's twice what the number of
kids that died in the 20 years in the
Vietnam War so we are we have two
Vietnam Wars a year that are now
happening in our country because of
addiction plus you've got all the
suicides and you know all the other uh
depression and this disintegration the
mental disintegration you know I think
there's uh 20,000 doses every year of of
um ssris another 120,000 of Aderall but
the people shouldn't you know lose hope
but what I'm going to do is I'm going to
start these um you work with a nonprofit
Community to start these Farms
essentially with Organic Farms where
people grow healthy food they live um
and it's based upon something that I saw
a relative of mine uh went to a place in
Italy called San padanos which is a um
which is a
community where they reparent you and
teach you how to be part of a community
awesome and um and there's no there's
2,000 kids who live there it's free
completely free awesome you just have to
make a long-term commitment you have to
commit to four years like college great
um you uh there's no cell phones there's
no screens you actually have to talk to
other people and then everybody is
taught a skill so they have a they have
a Furniture Factory they have a
wallpaper Factory they have one of their
greatest bakeries in Tuscany they you
know world famous bread they have a
Vineyard that make some of the finest
wine in Italy they have uh they have dog
kennels where people uh can you know
board their dogs and and you learn how
to take and then they have the same
thing for
horses and all these other and people
come out my um uh they they make purses
handmade purses for de Valley for prod
GUI um and they make money from selling
this stuff pays for half of their
budget and and these kids you know learn
how to live in communities for the first
time and they are you know they come out
completely
recovered oh um so cool I'm going to do
start these all over the country and you
know we're seeing that what we're seeing
in this country the disintegration of
any sense of community and any sense of
Pride people said on Instagram we self
love and in order to build self-esteem
you have to engage in esteemable actions
build something I made this I built this
I I got up and I went to work and I put
in a full day's work and showed up on
time to easy that's it Integrity
building Integrity I told the truth when
it was hard and all of that stuff that
kids aren't learning today and um and so
uh yeah I I mean I I really want to try
to restore this sense of community in
our country and you know you're people
are going to be living with people who
are Republicans and Democrats and all
different colors and uh and figuring out
how to you know reestablish the bonds of
community in our country that are being
you know destroyed right now we we
need to focus a lot right now at this
point in our history and self-healing
yep and uh we need to recover a lot of
these kids who are being lost
where are we on billionaires because you
know I was reading yesterday every now
and then I need to sort of get into the
Wormhole of of Bill Gates's new Venture
and I was reading about the app heal
he's putting on Costco apples he's
covering Costco apples with some
something some some some SCH smegma
condoms for apples I don't know if he's
just jealous that he didn't make apple
the software company now he to buy every
last apple he bought you know I don't
know about appal which is the name of it
but I don't eat those apples cuz you
know why would you if you can help it
but it makes it gives extends their
shelf like like a month or something and
then he bought brags which is the apple
cider vinegar which is a whole you know
sort of medicine a lot of people would
take if they don't want to take robot
Tustin or n or all these other things
and he puts appal apples in that now you
know so it's a full-time job just to
keep track of you know what this guy's
up to and then owning the you know
potatoes for McDonald's there's no way
potatoes aren't that delicious there's
something up with these fries like is he
owns the I thought Jr s plot can we look
that up P because I think he's got he
owns I the farmland for McDonald's
potatoes I bet you he still buys the
potatoes from Jrs and Blood Red River
trust an entity associated with Gates
bought the acreage located in the
northern Red River Valley from three
Campell Brothers according to spudman
Gates now owns 14,000 Acres of Farmland
Columbia Bay in Washington State
potatoes are grown to eventually become
McDonald's french fries so he's just on
that french fry
trip
wild wild to me yeah like I go back and
forth like you know on a laon musk it's
he's what he's he owns he's the biggest
owner of McDonald's he's the biggest
owner of
Coca-Cola he owns um he's the biggest
owner of caterpillar well caterpillar is
the trucks that farm the land yeah it's
like John deer's competitor Canadian
national Railway he owns
Railways well that he got from Warren
Buffett I think so that we can't leave
if we need to because of all the GMO
fries he's going to keep us in if his
GMO mosquitoes start attacking us
there's no way to get to Canada I mean
this guy's wild and I don't want to put
on the tinfoil hat and talk about the
Chemtrails and mosquitoes but is there
is the government is there a role if any
in terms of regulating not just
corporations but these billionaires that
just seem to be well I don't I
mean I I don't know I mean Gates but
Gates if you're single I'm available but
also we need to handle
you you think it would be worth it even
for 50 billion well I would justify it
as I'm going to get on the inside and
dismantle this monster I'll take one
I'll jump on this grenade I'm going to
go in there make him fall in love with
me and I'm going to stop appeal I'm
gonna stop you should have told your
plan on that I know stupid or should I
have right you think there's a certain
amount of money that just corrupts the
brain is this addiction gone wild I
don't know I mean I spent a lot of time
thinking about Gates because I wrote a
book about him yes but um and he had
there's patterns to his you know to his
strategy he calls it philanthropic
capitalism which is that you and and I
you know I'll tell you he did this with
Common Core Curriculum
where everybody gets you know is taught
kind of to learn my Microsoft
programming when they're is is trained
in in doing that so when they leave
school when they're in
school when they leave school that they
become customers um he did this with the
with the Green Revolution in Africa
which he financed he and the Rockefeller
foundation and the Green Revolution was
about converting Africans away from
traditional like sorghum and beans and
plantains and the the the sort of
sustainable agriculture that they had uh
that they had developed over 20,000
generations and switching them to GMO
corn um and he owns the GMO corn because
he owns a big chunk of
Monsanto and he owns and then Gill which
he brought in to do the supply
chain and the deal that they make with
Africa is that if you switch to Global
Commodities then we will uh we will not
only Supply you the fertilizer will
Supply the pesticides we will uh and
then we will buy the commodity at the
end of the
season and we will use it in our
products for McDonald's for craft he
also owns
Craft um and Coca-Cola the corn syrup
and the Coca-Cola Etc that was kind of
the with the Green Revolution and and
now as a result of that there are 30
million additional Africans who are
living on the edge of starvation and
during the
uh during the covid we shut down so now
all the now the people in Africa we
stopped importing all their corn we
stopped importing the the thing you know
so all the the promises of global
globalization that we made to the
African people back in
1996 um when Clinton was President and
Gates was driving the foreign policy um
those promises all got broken because
now that corn was left in heaps on the
on the docks and it wasn't being
ships and there were 10,000 African
children dying a month of
starvation of the lockdowns really
destroyed that whole illusion of of
globalization but you know it it was a
money-making Enterprise for Gates and
the vaccines the same thing he gives the
money gets tax deductions for giving the
money to the wh he gains control of the
who he he the wh pays for finance the
health ministries and virtually every
country in Latin in Africa so he can
then say as a condition of getting that
money this is what wh does as a
condition to get that money you have to
show that you vaccinated a certain
percentage of the of your
population is a milestone and but and
the vaccines that they're buying are
gate are owned by companies that Gates
own oh it's this system where you know
at the end the punchline on almost all
of his philanthropic Pro uh projects are
that he ends up making money oh I don't
look into his head and you know and and
speculate about why he thinks the way
that he does but he did the same thing
with Microsoft Microsoft was uh you know
it was a monopoly it's to control every
aspect to vertically vertically
integrate and control every aspect of
the of the domain of of the Landscapes
and then you know be able to monetize is
um philanthropy to make it to make
yourself richer it's the Revenge of the
Nerds whatever girl rejected him in high
school it is on you to come back and
sleep with him and fix close this Loop
whatever it is it just terrifies me I'm
just going to jump around a little bit
you know when I think about sort of uh
you know the carcinogens in the water I
mean you've been fighting this your
entire career um pollutants in the water
microplastics poisons does the
government just have no interest in PR
mention because they're not on the hook
for our
healthare well I think what um the the
answer that is that the
reason that that stuff is allowed
because the food industry controls FDA
so it's a captive agency it's like all
the other issues that the um they're not
you know FDA was supposed to protect
Public
Health but it's actually become a sock
puppet for the industry that it's
supposed to
regulate that's uh
now are
you are you do you did you go to West
Virginia to school or so my grandfather
West Virginia har Fair West Virginia he
worked in Cole uh you did a documentary
called The Last Mountain which I sobbed
the entire way through um I just you
know I know that your father had already
sort of started um yeah my family was
deeply linked West Virginia because West
Virginia primary back in 1960 only a few
States had primaries West Virginia
primary was critical because West
Virginia had the lowest number of
Catholics of any state H and it was
Notorious for uh it's anti Catholic
Prejudice um my you know before my uncle
ran Al Smith had run who was the
governor of New York and he was very
very popular at first and then people
found out he was a Catholic and it gave
rise
to kind of a reemergence of the Klux
Clan in the
country and uh and Native you know
nativist
bigotry and it uh and it killed his
presidency so there was kind of a a uh
uh let's say a belief a consensus that c
a Catholic could never run for president
of the United States so when my uncle
ran during the primary in 1960 he had to
prove that a Catholic could over come
that prejudice and the place that he had
to do that was West Virginia so you know
everybody agreed if he run West Virginia
that that was um that that showed that
he could get any c you know votes from
places that were traditionally any
Catholic so my whole family my mother
and father disappeared into West
Virginia when I was you know six years
old whoa and um and there were you know
they members of my family shook the
hands of literally everybody in West
Virginia during during that
election and they uh they put a huge
effort into the state and then they won
and that was a turning point in the
campaign and then the other thing that
happened is my uncle at a on a last
minute impulse he had been invited to
speak to the um the I think it it was
called the Protestant the Evangelical
ministers Association in Dallas MH and
he gave this famous speech he went down
there and he gave this famous speech
that they didn't ask me you know my
religion when I when they as when I they
sent me to war in the Pacific that
didn't my ask my brother's religion
before he died for our country because
his brother Joe had died during the
war and um you know he gave really this
extraordinary uh
uh I'd say t to
force about the importance of religious
freedom in America and um and it and he
got a sing evation at the end and that
kind of put the the issue behind him
well I mean w there's also a
complimentary documentary called
hillbilly to yours um about what
happened you know with Trump and Hillary
Hillary
said you know we got to get rid of Cole
She said and quote you guys did the best
you could to keep the lights on but it's
time to move to clean energy and by keep
the best you could they died they got
they went down there they never came
back they died and then Trump put on a
hard hat and he to Appalachia so you
know it's such an overlooked area um you
know something that is so close to my
heart also you know for people to look
at West Virginia as this backward area
it was the first woke State they said no
to slavery John Brown said no we're not
doing this anti slavery you know and now
it's thought of as this backward area
such a you know we've got this like
third world country right in the center
you know we're going to spend all this
money on Ukraine meanwhile why aren't we
rehabilitating West Virginia like you
know in terms of you know you know clean
energy nuclear energy all these new
energies like what can we do in order to
heal the traumatic Legacy of coal while
making sure coal miners are still taken
care of still have jobs but also
transitioning to something that's not
going to create such um incredible
pollution toxic air I mean I grew up
drinking poison West Virginia water so
it probably explains a
lot
yeah um and yeah and I mean you know if
you look at that film I my sister
also did a fil I think it was nominated
for an Academy Mard my baby sister uh
called American Hollow and it's about um
you know it's about life in West
Virginia um but and you know Cheryl went
to school in West Virginia I didn't know
that oh that's so cool went to the
University of West Virginia for a while
it's why she's America's sweetheart you
know that state just it just means so
much to me and it's so forgotten and I
just feel like politicians tend to not
go there and it really breaks my heart
yeah I mean in the the shrim one of the
things that strip mining did which is
now called mountaintop removal
mining is it really kind broke the umw
the United M workers in West Virginia
because the strip industry was not
unionized and they don't even advertise
for jobs in West Virginia they go down
to Myrtle Beach they go down
to um to uh to states that are very very
anti-union um to get workers and you you
know it used to be that uh that you uh
if you if you take mine from under the
ground it it's very labor intensive so
when my dad was uh fighting strip mining
West Virginia back in the 60s there
was uh
112,000 unionized miners in the state
today I think there's only
11,000 miners but and they're taking a
lot more coal out of West Virginia but
they're doing it very very now Capital
intensive they use these giant machines
called drag lines that are 22 stories
high I've literally flown under one in a
Piper
Cub um they and then they Ed hundreds of
tons of ammonia nitrate explosives they
in West Virginia they detonate the
equivalent of a hirosima nuclear bomb
every week to blow the tops off the
mountains to get at the coal seams
beneath and then they take all the
rubble and they plow it into the river
valley and you know they've buried 2200
miles of rivers and streams all
illegal uh but they get away with it CU
you know how the government is West
Virginia is owned by the coal industry
correct they pay for schools they pay
for the parades they send food to your
house you know and one of the most
despicable things they did I can speak
for I know Sinclair Oil is they would
pay their workers in vouchers to the
Sinclair store so that they couldn't
build wealth that's
that's that's an old scam Company Store
and something maybe I'll text Cheryl
about that we could work on together um
because I know she um uh obviously is
making movies now and getting sort of
more behind the camera and producing is
I was like you know why aren't we
shooting movies in West Virginia it
looks like Narnia we could shoot Lord of
the Rings there we could shoot all these
incredible you know draag why doesn't
you know uh um what is it Game of
Thrones shoot there I mean it looks like
New Zealand you know like let's put
money back into our small towns like
what a great way to do it so I'm
emailing with the tourism industry I'm
like trying to figure out the fil local
film industry West Virginia one of them
that runs tourism is a Hatfield and the
one that runs film is a
McCoy and they won't talk well you know
I I lived I lived in Alabama for almost
two years I lived in a little town
called l in Lou County called hanville
was 22 miles south of Montgomery and I
the guy I lived with was a guy called
sweepe Russ he was a Rodeo
Cowboy and he was driving home one night
and I I he'd been drinking
um and and it and he went past the exit
he must have blacked out or passed on
the car he hit the back of a U-Haul
trailer and knocked it over the the
front of the car and it was a it was a
family from uh from West
Virginia that was moving to Florida and
they had all their worldly possessions
in that and they were in a station wagon
and luckily he hit this Ule a cushion
the blows they didn't nobody got hurt
thank God but I went there the next day
to help them clean up the mess cuz all
of their possessions were all over the
highway and I we came on a high school
yearbook and every single person and it
was either called Hatfield or
McCoy obsessed yeah the same thing
totally obsessed um but you know um you
you're talking about the
landscapes in appal Ria and it it's
interesting because it's the richest
ecosystems in North America and the
reason for that is during the pan Ice
Age which was 20,000 years ago there
were two miles of ice over where I lived
in New York over the Hudson Valley and
the rest of North America became a
tundra so there were no trees left and
the only place that the American Forest
survived was in Appalachia and then when
the ice
withdrew North America was re ceeded
from those Appalachian Forest so um the
typical forest in this
country um on the you know east coast
forest like in Vermont or Georgia has
three dominant tree species in
Appalachia there is 80 because just the
richness of that ecosystem so it's
literally it's the mother ecosystem of
all North America it's the richest you
know more species per cubic meter than
any other place in North America America
and it's really a crime that we're
cutting it all down we've cut down these
coal companies PE console Massi have got
down uh 1.4 million Acres the flatten
the 500 biggest mountains of West
Virginia are
gone they flatten an area larger than
the state of Delaware 1.4 million acres
and it it's a sterilized ecosystem after
that so and then they buried all the
rivers it's really uh if people have
Americans knew this is the purple
mountains Majesty the these are the
Landscapes where Daniel bro and Davey
Crockett roam so much of our culture you
know bluegrass music NASCAR racing all
of these you know these iconic parts of
American culture Racial equality
yeah exactly and um when I'm talking
about this area it makes me hopeful it
um you know makes my heart expand it
does uh remind me of of one thing that
last time I I visited someone that was
horribly injured and his whole family
family was injured from coal said
something um that broke my heart who
said if they hadn't taken all the coal
by now we'd probably have diamond mines
you know like they're taking these you
know literal uh natural resources well
you know my father used to say about
West Virginia it's the richest state in
the
country but it has the poorest
population it goes it competes with
Mississippi for having the you know the
poorest population every year they go
back and forth but um and it's because
you know the minds I mean Massie go is
not locally owned people conso are not
they're all owned by Wall Street oh the
M you know the the Coal's being stri
mind from the people and all that those
coal Fields were purchased by you know
by Hustlers who went in there and Scout
what they call scall Wags and carpet
Packers went into the
state uh after the Civil War and they
would pay people land owners for the
subsurface rights to their property and
if you're a poor land owner who's
starving and they say to you um you know
somebody says to you there's coal under
here and one day somebody May mine it we
want to own you know it we'll pay you
money that right in the future and you
think it's going to be a tunnel mind
that's not going to really disturb your
um your use and enjoyment of your
property you take the money so it was
all sold it was all bought and then it
was Consolidated and sold to these
really three giant companies and um and
then they came in and said well actually
now we're going to actually blow your
farm up to get it the coal and people
would say you can't do that um and
they'd go to the West Virginia Supreme
Court which is owned by the coal
industry coal industry he said yeah if
you got to get at the coal you can blow
up the farm now even I want to say five
six years ago Alan mus tried to bring in
a Tesla Factory with union labor and
they chased him out he was like I've
never seen anything like this yeah you
know because they wouldn't even they
wouldn't even let him in yeah I mean
it's just it's absolutely it's it feels
so hopeless sometimes but they do show
up and vote and one thing I will say is
um we proudly say the word redneck here
um you know because of course that um
dates back to the Battle of Blair
Mountain where the the labor Uprising
where everyone had a red handkerchief
you know so every now and then in this
sort of moment where no one's allowed to
say anything and these words you know
you say this and that I say I'm proudly
white trash and and you know hillbilly
and um a redneck people like you can't
say redneck I'm like you think it's you
made up some other term for it but
actually where in West Virginia it means
you're a hero uh yeah and the Battle of
Blair
Mountain was a uh was a battle uh it was
the only time in American history when
US Air Force bombers have been deployed
against American citizens inside America
and there was
20,000 uh Union protesters on Blair
Mountain who were trying to get decent
wages and uh uh and the government uh
the coal company which owned the United
States government at that time got them
to deploy the United States Air Force
and in its in its earliest years one of
the first actions the United States Air
Force was bombing uh and and
strafing miners striking miners in West
Virginia oh that's real you know
corporate capture Dark Water that Mark
Ruffalo movie is about you know after
Cole then came in Dupont then I have
umbrella Insurance specifically so I can
talk about
dupons because I had my business manager
because I'm always like in Dupont
spilling chemicals and West Virginia
he's like can you please take that down
um but um you know and then it's just
over and over again and the chemical
spills and now the you know the opioid
crisis it always just seems to go
straight for Appalachia every time yeah
so that uh movie was made about my case
which was that you know
suing um dupon on pfoas which are flame
and they were they called C8 at
the time and they were Teflon is that uh
it's part it's in Teflon yes and that's
why Teflon you know was making people
sick because when Teflon starts you
should never use teflon uh cated band
because if it if it starts to smoke when
it heats up it volatize the pfoas and
then you inhale it and it's uh you know
it's making people very very
sick um but it also isn't the water and
it poisoned 10,000 people in that part
of Ohio and West
Virginia and uh you know we sued them
then we we ended up winning the three
lawsuits and then settling for the you
know 10 10,000 families there um I also
brought a case against tupon in West
Virginia and I did the final argu the
closing argument in the case and I think
and it was in spelter West Virginia
where Dupont was running as Inc smelter
and had poisoned the entire town knew
they were all
poison they there there was actually a
memo in the case where they said we need
to tell these people here's a press
release and then Deon met and said let's
not tell them and because they're people
were saying you know the executives in
the company say we need to tell them so
they stop drinking their water because
we're poisoning them all and here is a
model press release that we're going to
use to inform the town and then the
executives Depon said it's better not to
tell him and they let him drink it for
another 20 years and when you went
around that town it was you could look
at people and just say these something's
wrong here the tour guides there were
tour guides that were getting thyroid
cancer of the New River and you know the
people that would canoe swim in the
river I mean a lot of people that I went
to school with their kids had thyroid I
mean it's just it's beyond comprehension
yeah do you think part of the reason
they were able to get away with that is
because it was a lot of Italians it was
a lot of Scotch Irish they looked at
them as immigrant labor at the time or
I'm trying to get yeah I I mean I don't
know how much of that there was but
probably yeah they were um you know I
think a lot of them were World War I
veterans um who had got I mean West
Virginia has more Medal of Honor winners
I think than any other state despite the
small population West Virginia and
Puerto Rico I think are the
highest uh concentration of metal AR
Honor winners and there was this Scotch
Irish population that was you know very
very um uh had fought in the Civil
War and it became kind of a tradition to
you know to be um uh to be you know part
of the this a Scotch Irish tradition to
go into the military and there's a great
book called Born fighting about that a
gy yeah yeah that's my ancestry so
whenever somebody's like why do you
always have to be so contr I'm like this
is just my ancestor I don't know what to
tell you I just um and uh it's like the
definition of well balanced
Irishman is having a chip on both
shoulders but Jim webs you know Jim Web
was a United States Senator I think he
had seven generations of uh of War of
you know awarded war heroes in his
family his son who is a Marine in Iraq
is running Veterans Affairs for my
campaign wow
that's so
cool I'm letting you go because I know
you have a million things one thing I
have not by the way I love your podcast
um I didn't want to ask you any
questions you've already answered on
there um but uh I cannot recommend it
enough you sometimes just 30 minute
bites total Game Changer um obviously
you've done some amazing podcasts with
Rogan and Lex Etc one thing I haven't
heard though uh is how you proposed to
Cheryl when I I proposed to show first
of all I went and asked permission Larry
and that was but I went I was in
Florida and we were in a a sort of a a
mangrove we were on the uh we were on
the banks of the St John's river and we
were in kind of a you know all these uh
Southern Oaks with a with the uh Spanish
moss coming off with her her nieces and
nephews and her daughter
and they asked me if I was going to
marry Cheryl and I already made up my
mind oh um I said yeah do you want to
see me proposed to her and she they said
yeah and so I got down on my knees and
no ring anything just they took a
picture of it which
is but um yeah I didn't have it ring on
me at that point it was real love it was
real love okay okay we get it you have
real love thank you so much for coming
by I don't want to keep you I don't want
to be selfish with the time but I'm just
such a big fan of yours and I hope I
didn't I'm a huge fan of yours I hope I
didn't make you repeat too much oh let
me just tell you one more thing it was
very it was uh it was mainly new stuff
so that's really an accomplishment I um
also wrote my senior honors thesis on
the postmodern implications of Oliver
Stone's JFK so this day was coming
regard yeah yeah yeah oh we need to come
back and talk about that another time
yeah but that has um been a very long
Obsession of mine for you know
my my dad was on to this way before um
also played Harvard football my dad oh
really yeah we have lots of weird
Centric things God he would be
77 right now so he was 10 years younger
than my dad yeah he got asked to leave
cuz he would fight fighting he was born
fighting that's funny that's our thing
oh anyway next time I come back maybe
you'll have some family photos yes we
have to house the fact that he came and
he's like you have no no photos of
anyone in this house he's like is this a
stage house like like Tom Cruz has that
Scientology house it's just has no just
a fake House cartoons and horses it's so
sad yeah I know I've got horses I've got
well this room I mean the people are
watching this this room actually has a
lot of character and imprint on it but
the rest of the house could be it's kind
of auster there's very I want to be very
simple very calming and then here is
just the total this is like the inside
of my brain just complete chaos and uh
stuff that sent and just you know all
the rig roll so thank you for coming by
I end these awkwardly and as always
don't ride elephants I always end saying
remember when Bob Barker said spay a new
to your pets at the end remember when he
would say that at the end of every Price
is Right spay a new to your pets it made
a really big difference in um awareness
about it so I was like let me pick one
thing to say and so I say don't ride
eleph okay
yeah so don't do that today thank you
it's too late for
me
[Music]
a